[Musique]
1988 jo de calgary au canada ils sont 4
4 bober prêt à partir casque jaune sur
la tête jusque là rien d'extraordinaire
pour des jeux d'hiver sauf que ces
quatre athlètes sont les bobeurs
jamaïcain
[Applaudissements]
en jamaïque il n'y a ni neige et encore
moins de piste de bobsleigh pour cette
île des caraïbes
c'est une première jamais elle n'avait
participé aux épreuves de bob j aux
divers derrière cette idée un peu folle
il y à un homme georges fitch un homme
d'affaires américain un ami a fait un
pari avec moi monter une équipe
olympique pour les jeux d'hiver de
calgary seulement cinq mois avant les
jeux
alors j'ai tenu le pari il fallait
seulement déterminer quels sports hockey
patinage ski de fond non j'ai dit ce
sera le bob
pour trouver ces bober georges fritsch
va même jusqu'à organiser des sélections
au sein de l'armée jamaïcaines michael
white stephen harris 2les staut et son
frère chris sont choisis trois d'entre
eux sont des militaires aucun des
professionnels la la la la la la la la
et face à cette équipe les journalistes
sont amusés voire même un peu moqueurs
qui est les mecs qui te redonne rentrer
la tête dans les épaules
le erik thon rouge de la torte juin dans
la coquille pour cette épreuve de bob à
4 la jamaïque finira non classés après
la chute de leur bobsleigh mais le pays
marquent définitivement l'esprit
olympique après calgary le bop jamaïcain
revient en 1981 pour les jo
d'albertville en france on n'est pas des
professionnels c'est dur de financer
notre sport alors nous le faisons
vraiment vraiment sérieusement
puis en 1994 pour les jeux de
lillehammer en norvège 2 les stoks déjà
présent en 1988 est toujours dans
l'équipe
qu'un début nous sommes là pour
longtemps et nous montrerons de quoi
nous sommes capables et ça continue la
jamaïque est régulièrement présente aux
épreuves de bob des jo d'hiver nagano en
1998 photo l'ex city en 2002 ou encore
sotchi en 2014
et malgré des résultats peu probants
la motivation reste intacte nous n'avons
pas glaçons jamais ou alors seulement
dans le réfrigérateur
mais être là signifie tellement pour
notre pays en 2022 à pékin la jamaïque
est une nouvelle fois présente à des
jeux d'hiver c'est leur huitième
participation à des épreuves de bob
depuis 1988 et pour la première fois le
pays concourent dans trois catégories le
bob à 4 le bob à deux et le monobloc
femina
[Musique]